-Our first guest tonight
is an Associate Justice
to the United States
Supreme Court.
Her new children's book,
"Just Help: How to Build
a Better World"
was published today.
Please welcome back to the show
justice Sonia Sotomayor.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, Justice!
How are you?
-I'm well, Seth.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing good.
Are you -- are you
technically in chambers
right now?
-I'm technically
in the courthouse,
not in my private office.
-Okay, because I would love --
I would love for you
to say right now that I'm seeing
you in your chambers
because that is like --
The dream in my life is to be an
attorney and have a judge say,
"See me in my chambers."
-[ Laughs ]
-If you want,
I'll tell you that,
and you can come visit me
at some point.
-One day I would love to be.
I'd love to be in someone's
chambers, just once.
-Just once, come visit.
[ Laughs ]
Congratulations on the book,
"Just Help."
You had a previous book,
"Just Ask."
I see a theme here.
What was the difference with
"Just Help?"
And did you always know
that you were going
to write a second book?
-A third.
I started -- this is my third
children's book.
The first was a story
of my life, "Turning Pages"
and how books influenced me.
As I think you might remember,
"Just Ask" was a book that I had
in my head for 30 years.
And when it came to life,
it was satisfying that dream.
And this one just helped,
really, as a continuation
of my life commitment
as a justice to inspiring kids
to know their power
to change the world,
and I think that's the most
important work I do.
Yeah, the opinion writing helps
a little bit in my work.
But I do think that writing for
kids and writing about topics
that I think that can inspire
them to believe in
themselves, that that's the most
important thing
I can do outside
the courtroom.
-When it comes to being...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Absolutely.
When it comes to being helpful,
I heard that is something
that your mother instilled
in you at a young age.
Did you appreciate as a kid
how important it was
to be helpful
to those around you?
-No, because you learn
by example,
and I saw my mother doing it.
I saw my grandmother and my Aunt
doing it in different ways.
And watching others who I love
taking small acts of improving
the world, I never understood
that one person
doesn't change the world, but
everybody working together can.
And that's what my mother taught
me, by her example of being
the nurse to the entire
neighborhoods we lived in,
to our family,
but to friends and neighbors
and neighbors she didn't know.
People would hear about my mom
and that she was a nurse.
They'd walk up to our door and
knock, and I'd answer it.
I didn't know
who the person was,
neither did mom,
and they'd say something like,
"I'm having a medical issue.
Could I talk to you?"
And inevitably, it would be
they needed some help
taking medication, and my mother
would always say yes
and just do it out of the
goodness of her heart.
I had an aunt, my mother's
sister, who was very, very poor.
She lived in the South Bronx,
and her income was decidedly
lesser than almost any other
member of the family.
And yet I watched her every
Thanksgiving and Christmas
going through her kitchen
and my mother's kitchen
and putting together packages
of food to give people
less fortunate than us.
And I didn't see those acts
of what people think of
as kindness, but they're really
civic participation.
They're participating in making
your neighborhood
and your community better.
And so as I grew up, I figured
out, you know something?
They set an example for me.
Now I have to follow it.
And you can do small things,
like mom.
They weren't so small,
but they were very important
to the people
they were doing it for.
But you could take small steps,
then bigger steps.
And this book, "Just Help,"
is about some of those
bigger steps kids can take.
just because you're a kid
doesn't mean
you're not powerful.
[ Applause ]
-Now, I'm wondering,
have you heard from kids who
read your books?
Are they aware they are reading
a children's book
that is written
by a Supreme Court justice?
Or do they just think you're a
very successful children's
author who also has a side gig?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what the kids
initially think,
but I do know their parents
kind of tell them along the way.
So by the time
they finish the book,
they know what my day job is.
But I did have a very young
child whose mother told me
her favorite book was about me,
and her mother read it to her
every single night.
And she asked me whether
she could bring her child
to meet me,
and I said absolutely yes.
And the little girl walked
into my office and looked at me,
looked all around, and couldn't
find the figure of me
that she had seen in the book.
She didn't realize
I had grown up.
[ Laughter ]
So she was a little
disappointed.
I've received letters
from her since,
telling me about her life.
I think she figured it out.
But you know, it's hard
to know what kids think.
They see you on television.
And sometimes they wonder,
how is it that you come out of
the television to talk to them?
-I find with my kids, the moment
I'm having now is, you know,
a lot of actors who are voices
in animated movies
that my kids watch
have been on this show.
And I'll say, "You know, daddy
talked to that actor,"
and I'll show a clip.
And they just immediately are
like, "I don't like this."
[ Laughter ]
I don't like seeing that bear
as a human being.
-I expect that that is true,
and I know kids must have that
reaction every once in a while.
I also tell kids all the time,
"You know, I'm going to do
something that disappoints you.
I'm going to issue --" and I
tell adults this, too.
"I'm going to issue a decision
someday that you don't like.
That's the nature of my job,
to do what the law says.
That doesn't always accord to
what you may think is right.
So you have to understand that
I'm a human being."
And I think when you step out
of the TV and present yourself
as a person, that kids might
have a little bit of a hard time
accepting that you're
a real human being
and not just an image
on that screen.
But your kids know
the real human being,
and I'm sure they prefer that
to this personality.
What do you think?
-I think so, too.
You know, I want to say
something.
You are a real human being that
I always enjoy talking to,
despite the fact
that you're a Yankees fan.
And that's very hard
for me to say.
-Seth.
-Yes.
Before you razz me
for last year,
remember one very
important thing.
The arc of the universe always
bends towards justice,
and we will come back.
[ Laughter ]
-Then I'll leave it at that.
I will leave it at that.
Justice Sonia Sotomayor,
everybody.
"Just Help: How to Build a
Better World" is available
wherever you buy your books,
but remember to support
local and independent
book stores.